he's done miracles on me
he's done miracles on me
kanye west and kim kardashian recreated
their wedding at his donda listening
event in chicago on thursday now a
source tells e.t that a romantic
reconciliation might be a possibility
e.t source explains quote kanye wants to
get back with kim and he has been trying
to win her over again and reproof
himself at the end of the day life is
about being happy
being who you are
and
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
kim filed for divorce from kanye back in
february after nearly seven years of
marriage they share four children
together eight-year-old north
five-year-old saint three-year-old
chicago and two-year-old psalm and have
remained on good terms since their split
in fact kim attended all three donda
listening events and was recently
spotted having lunch with kanye in
malibu him and i have been best friends
for a really long time and just been in
each other's lives
kim and kanye have a deep love for each
other and many amazing memories and it's
difficult to just let that all go kim's
main focus and concern are her children
and doing what is best for them and
their family
according to the source that means the
reality star is considering her options
with kanye but keeping her kids top of
mind quote she is open to seeing where
things go with kanye and to see if they
can work through their issues as a
couple regardless of what happens kim
and kanye plan to co-parent in a healthy
way and will always maintain a
supportive relationship i always believe
and trust in him i know his heart on
sunday kim showed her support for the
rapper posting screenshots as she
listened to his new album which dropped
earlier that morning after a roughly one
month delay though kanye claimed on
instagram that dondo was released by his
label universal music without his
approval
kim gave the album her stamp of approval
he is the best i love him e.t has
reached out to kanye and universal for
comment
and while kim and kanye continue to
navigate their new relationship they
sure know how to keep people talking
he's done miracles on me
he's done miracles
[Music]
you